this Liz truss resigns and will become
shortest serving PM in British history
uh she's resigned prime minister just
after 44 days from uh over taking over
Boris Johnson she will be the shortest
servant PM in British history and a
statement outside uh Downing Street
trust admitted she could not deliver her
mandate she said I came into office at a
time of great economic and international
instability families and businesses were
worried about how to pay their bills she
said she was elected with a mandate to
change this adding we delivered on
energy bills I recognize though given
her this situation I cannot deliver the
Mandate on which I was elected by the
conservative party so one was she
somebody that most of the conservatives
were happy about uh did they want to
replace Boris with her and two her
reasoning for resigning is this a good
thing for UK or a bad thing I mean she
had to go so we were waiting for I guess
a day but we're kind of saying it was
down to the hour so you knew you knew
this was coming
toe that once she came in with her
measures the markets reacted really
badly to those measures so the pound
just plummeted we were at parity with
the dollar for the first time in modern
history
um very weird it was crazy borrowing
weights went through the roof so
mortgages went through the roof in terms
of people who were looking to fix a
mortgage and so the markets basically
decided she was gone so she was already
kind of a dead woman walking
um she was brought in people preferred
Boris Johnson old money preferred Boris
Johnson so she we always knew she
wouldn't be around for long and it was
humiliating I don't enjoy yeah iceberg
lettuce in blonde wig at last list trust
I don't know if I really enjoy I know
you boys might enjoy that well I don't
know if I enjoy seeing it did you like
her did you actually like her no she's
robotic and weird I got you what I'm
what I really would love is if if
Britain had
um democracy that people could believe
in but honestly ordinary Brits a bit
like what we were talking about earlier
their daily concern at the minute is
they can't afford to heat their houses
they can't afford to buy stuff in the
store we now have something called heat
banks in the UK where old people are
supposed to go and heat themselves in
the day in public buildings because they
can't afford to heat their own homes I
mean it's a fairly dire situation I
suspect what we'll see well we're either
going to see Rishi sunac or we're going
to see Boris Johnson come back into play
and the latest rule that they've made up
is that 100 MPS whoever's going to run
has to have the support of 100 MPS so
it's going to be a very very fast
competition to see who's going to
replace Liz Trump I mean this is not
normal though right 44 days 44 days the
longest was what 142 and 124 some number
like that that was in 1896 um so the
rate 130 years ago the race she was in
to be prime minister was longer than the
time she spent as prime minister that's
that's a again so purely the the money
people didn't support it because the
economy was being felt under policies
and that's like we got to move on okay
she was gone got it so and and How
likely is it that a Boris is going to
come back because people are just kind
of saying look let's just get him back
in here he was safe he was good he was
is that kind of what it's most likely
gonna happen good play going on there's
a weird dynamic Rishi sunak is what I
think the party would want I think it's
what the Marcus markets would want I
think it's what globalists would want
you know they love him because he's a
Montecito boy over in California with a
green card and the richest wife actually
in England you might want to Google that
um but I um think the people in the UK
loved Boris so if we then went to a
general election who could win still for
the conservative party not Rishi but
Boris could did you like him did you
like Boris I liked him right up until
the point he locked down my country
got him do we have an example by the way
do you remember like if I recall I
remember you know you can fact check me
on this I don't know why I remember him
saying uh herd immunity is the way to go
the only way to solve this and that's
kind of what he was pitching at exactly
he said that right yeah right until the
point that whoever got to him whatever
somebody's Pfizer somebody either money
I agree 100 but it's either money or
it's either they had something on him
because I remember everybody you looked
at from the past and you looked at like
even the interview without you years ago
where he says if somebody has this
should they give access no that's the
ultimate you know magazine that's the
best vaccine so real quick how much of
that do you think had to do with Boris
getting coveted Boris got coveted bad he
was hospitalized he did that I think
that had a lot to do with it I think
it's that or the fact that they had
blacked me he had a bit of a code for a
while and then he went and he was
allegedly in intensive care and we were
all supposed hurricane said he came out
of that thing and he turned on dime and
all of a sudden everything he said
before heard immunity masks don't work
why would he but here I am shaking hands
with people still because oh it's all a
load of old crap that's where he was I
turned on a dime whatever they gave him
or whatever they had or what they have
on it probably Epstein Island video with
like Hey listen bro we got this video
but you know what though that is the
ultimate like that's what we don't know
yeah you know that's what we don't know
and it's a very very effective method
yeah because you're coming here saying
Hey listen man you're 60 something years
old here's what we found on you how do
you want your legacy to end up we're
going to go public with this next week
unless if you don't dot dot dot oh my
god do you not believe that stuff
happens I believe it does 100 that
happens and then they have you forever
because you have to say the course or
else that video or whatever they have on
you that person that's gonna come out
yeah is always going to be in your
Shadow well listen I mean it's credible
to Kim Kardashian she made it more than
listed 72 days I know Tyler just put
this yeah uh 44 days versus 72 days is
that kind of is this a form of
recognition from you Tyler
here's what I would be curious about on
who's more likely to make a comeback him
or Netanyahu I would be very curious to
know which one of those two guys
or uh boars yeah
well
wouldn't I would love it to be BB but
Boris is already on his way back from
the Caribbean and doing his hair
yeah his hair just changed and that
means that means big things are a foot
when has he ever changed I've never seen
him fix his hair I've never seen him
yesterday he had his hair slightly fit
seriously slightly
Liz I know I know I know listen I'm not
defending
but he does I I guess intentionally do
this to be more of a comment because
he's an Oxford man very smart guy he's
not an idiot he plays sort of like the
bumbling fool he literally does like a
Chris Farley impression shakes up his
hair and he's like all right let's go be
British for a second exactly that's true
totally and that picture which we can
find with Google I'm supporting this now
I'm not having a go if you get Boris on
zip wire
um that's that to me is the what this
was with him when he was London mayor
and it's the epitome of how Boris wanted
to present himself right so he's up on
the zip wire look there oh God and then
the zip where I went wrong oh no
is hilarious on the zip wire but in many
ways it was all of our favorite moment
because it was London at its best we
were just about to have the Olympic
Games and he's stuck up there on a
bloody zip wire and just really quick
practice I wanna I wanna ask Katie just
okay I mean there's a lot happening with
you know maybe coming back Boris coming
back uh what's your name of resigning
what about the the Georgia Maloney
they consider her for every article that
I've read from BBC to everybody she's
just far right she's gonna start a war
it's all bad but it's in a couple hours
I guess there's they're gonna the the
brittle the the it's gonna switch today
isn't it yes where they're gonna give
her power today how do you feel about
her I love her I love I love the fetches
Italian I love the fact she's called
Maloney
like pizzas come out of here for me I
love the fact that if you're an [ __ ]
and you believe in Google then you
believe she's far right whereas actually
she's so perfectly excellent in all her
ways and she's also backed up because of
the way the Italian voting system works
she has a salvini as well Matteo's
Salvage who I've met who's the greatest
man he's gonna be like her sidekick oh
wow there's like a band of them so it's
perfect and also we had same in Sweden
Swedish Democrats so we're we're having
a good run this run is gonna she's a the
difference between her and Alyssa or
Boris she seems like a real conservative
that's gonna stand up she doesn't she
seems Fearless I love her I mean it's so
far out of me you know said something he
says look we have no clue who this
person is this just came out of nowhere
so far she seems very Fearless uh very
clear in her messaging backbone yeah
she's and if you watch like her speeches
in front of the Italian times
it was it was like a speaker like it was
just I listened to every single I mean I
had to read it but it was passionate I I
it might be BS or whatever Adam I feel
you but I believed her Vinnie what Benny
did is Vinnie was so impressed that he
started looking if she has any daughters
because he has entry I love him I look
Italian her name is Vinnie yeah hey man
the word on the street is you've
actually been hanging out with more
Italian people around town here 100 100
Bertolucci a lot of these restaurants
because nobody believes when I say a
middle eastern like yeah all right
witness protection so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]